- The CIFAR Azrieli
Global Scholars Program
has accelerated my
career by introducing me
to scholars from diverse
disciplines all over the world
who share many of my challenges,
but also have inspired me
to think about my research in new ways.
- These meetings are often
like a who's who in the field,
and what's been very
valuable for me is that,
a lot of these international CIFAR Fellows
and CIFAR Global Scholars
have actually been the most
incisive critics of my work,
and that kind of opportunity
to engage with them in a very
friendly manner helps a lot.
- The unrestricted
funds that I've received
as a CIFAR Azrieli Global Scholar
was really valuable to me.
It allowed me to pursue a
lot of high-risk directions
that I wouldn't be able
to pursue otherwise
at this stage in my career.
- The mentorship
opportunities are incredible.
You are placed in contact
with luminaries in the field
who will actually take
an interest in your case
and help you think about
how to guide your research
to maximum impact.